jada i love you g.i jane too can't wait
to see it all right
[Applause]
[Music]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
so now i want to show you a selection of
uh tweets
several of them deleted by uh democrats
and lefty politicians about what
happened because you know we've been
told for a while that words are violence
so if you believe that words are
violence then i guess violence is
violence in in the name of words this is
this is a real problem here's ayanna
presley she's a congresswoman she is a
member of the squad she happens to have
alopecia she says alopecia nations stand
up thank you will smith shout out to all
the husbands who defend their wives
living with alopecia in the face of
daily ignorance and insults
oscars women with baldies are for real
men only wait what women with baldies
are for real men only boys boys need not
apply and there she is and and she's got
the the shaved head too so
she deleted that tweet because basically
she's saying yeah you're allowed to
punch people people are allowed to uh
make jokes and your response should be
that you hit people again this should
not surprise us these are the words are
violence
people okay these are the same people
that say if you say something we're
allowed to burn down a building or break
a window et cetera et cetera now i want
to talk about alopecia for a minute
because many of you know this i wrote
about it in my first book don't burn
this book um i suffered from alopecia
about five years ago for about two years
and it was quite horrific uh conor can
you throw up so the image that i'm
showing you on the left it was
significantly worse than this i don't
know where all the images are and i
didn't really feel like looking for them
because it was pretty bad but this was
sort of halfway through when actually
some of my hair was growing back and it
started with uh you know sort of quarter
size or dime sized little spots losing
hair all the time it moved up really to
the front of my head and everything else
the picture you're seeing on the right
uh that's from a couple months back uh
when my hair was was fully back you know
alopecia it's an autoimmune disease and
they don't know exactly what causes it i
went for all the blood tests and all the
other stuff and i was fine they so they
chalk it up to stress usually and
interestingly when i developed alopecia
um it was right when i started talking
about what was wrong with the left when
i still consider myself a lefty and i
was just getting unending hate online
people saying the worst
most awful things and it was the first
time in my life i was ever dealing with
that and i guess i wasn't dealing with
the stress properly
and i was just losing chunks and chunks
of hair this is all my hair
i mentioned in the book how how i dealt
with it i changed my diet a lot got rid
of a lot of sugar got rid of a lot of
carbs
i did prp which is platelet-rich plasma
they take your blood they literally take
your blood flow arm they spin it in the
centrifuge they get the plasma from your
blood and they inject it into your head
and it gets your cells going it's rather
extraordinary people do it for all all
sorts of things i've done it for my knee
as well
anyway the point is whether you have
alopecia or not i am not allowed to
punch people who make fun of
me when i had bald spots in the back of
my head and i was using paint i mean i
was literally doing my show and i would
use like goo paint and spray on stuff
and powders to do that i couldn't just
punch somebody who was mean to me but
this is what
many people
on the modern left believe
here's another representative
congressman jamal bowman here's what he
said teachable moment don't joke about a
black woman's hair and then of course he
deleted that as well
no you're allowed to joke about people
and then people are allowed to make fun
of you they're allowed to not associate
with you um they're allowed to mock you
and all of those things they're not
allowed to physically assault you
this is what laws are we have freedom of
speech and if someone says something
mean to you you can ignore them or you
can say something mean to them
but you can't attack them here's a tweet
from a university of florida professor
his name's michael mcdonald he said will
smith just showed ted cruz what a real
man does when somebo someone belittles
their wife so again violence is okay
when you're offended this should not i
think you see what i'm doing here
everything that that these last you know
five or six years have has been about
has led us to this that it will be okay
to just assault people now interestingly
and this is a sort of sidebar and i did
not know this uh but several people have
mentioned it and my guys mentioned it
this morning will smith happens to be in
an open marriage now you can judge that
or not judge that if if they're fully
happy in their marriage and they feel
fully actualized and they're both having
sex with other people i don't know
exactly what that means or do they bring
other people in the bedroom or anything
else but basically you can bang will
smith's wife but you can't make a joke
about her that seems to be where we're
roughly at in this thing